I remember one time a woman like I  thought she raised her hand to ask a  question but she just had like cerebral  palsy and I was just like man and then I  was just like oh and like what do you do  and so oh my God the flop sweat I'm like  taking off the tiny tank top I have like  just anything to get me out of this and  then just getting naked on stage to  change the vibe  if I'm a bad person I'm gonna get  canceled I hurt this person's feelings  you can't think clearly in that moment  but I'd like to try in those times my  goal is always to like if I'm joke bombs  or something I said something awkward is  just stop and say like what is true like  what's true that's gonna get me out of  it acknowledge the elephant in the room